Tonight I'ma tell you how
my big titties saved my life.
[cheers and applause]
So, it was the summer of 1988.
I'm 16 years old,
I got two kids,
two and one years old,
and I'm living in the hood
in Atlanta.
And in this hood, you know,
I'm trying to survive.
So, I go out
and start me a small business.
Well, I was selling crack,
but we gonna call it
a small business tonight.
Okay, white people?
'Cause when you 16 years old
in the hood
and you got two kids,
there's only two things
you can do for a job.
Either sell drugs
or sell your body.
So, I did the one
that paid the most.
So, I had to advertise
this business.
And I couldn't go out, you know,
and try to get no [bleep]
commercial or no flashy signs
or no shit like that.
So, I had to advertise the way
we do in the hood.
I went out and bought me
a 1980 Fleetwood Cadillac
from the junkyard for $500.
And I put $9,500 into it.
Rims and paint.
So, I take this car
and I paint it pearl white,
with 1,001 gold flakes in it.
And white people, you probably
don't know what the hell
I'm talking about,
but when you got a paint job
with 1,001 gold flakes,
you the shit in the hood.
So, I'm sitting in my car
one day with one of my clients,
running inventory
through my small business.
I always had to keep a client
in the car with me,
'cause I was 16 years old
with a learner's permit,
and I didn't want to risk
the chance
of losing my [bleep] permit.
[laughter]
So, I'm sitting there one day,
and one of my rivals walk up,
and he hit the back of my car.
And he's just yell, Rabbit,
get the hell out of the car
with your fat ass.
Now, Rabbit is my hood name.
'Cause you can't go
by your real name in the hood.
Patricia don't sound tough
at all.
I get out the car
and we arguing,
and he [bleep] spit on my car.
Now, it wasn't a regular spit,
people.
'Cause I wouldn't have got mad.
It was the type of spit that
he pulled from his damn navel.
The first thing
I'm thinking, like,
this [bleep] done [bleep]
chipped one of my gold flakes.
I paid a lot of money
for that paint job.
So, I go to my car
'cause I got to be tough,
and I'm a girl.
I reach in the car
and grab my baby bag,
and I move the Pampers over.
Then I move the crack over.
Then I get my pistol.
'Cause you know
I'm a good mama.
You got to keep all the shit
together.
And so I take my gun
and I stick it to his dick.
And I said, now,
get that shit off of my car
before I turn your dick
into a blooming onion.
[laughter]
He wiped the spit off.
And I said, now,
get the hell out of here.
He walks away.
He get halfway up the hill
and he turn around
and he was, like,
when I come back, bitch,
I'ma kill you.
Now, I'm from the hood.
You hear that shit every day.
You don't believe it
till they lay you down.
White people, don't let
this white guilt get you, okay?
Relax, this shit is funny.
And five minutes later,
I'm serving customers
and he come back.
Now, he's shooting.
Now, I don't know
if you ever been in a shootout
with black people before,
but when they come
down the hill and they running
and they shoot, I think
that make the bullets go faster.
[laughter]
But I want to shoot back
'cause I got my pistol
in my hand.
But what I realized,
my pistol wouldn't shoot
because the shit was on safety.
Now, I don't know if you ever
been in a shootout before,
but if you're ever in a shootout
and you shooting,
and your shit on safety, you
not in a shootout any longer.
[laughter]
You being shot at.
So, I take off running,
and I'm running down the hill,
and my [bleep] titties
just flying in my face.
And I'm trying
to hold my titties down.
'Cause you know,
these titties young.
They took off running
before I did.
I run down the hill,
and I jumped over this fence,
and I run into
my girlfriend house.
She was, like, why you got blood
all over your shirt?
And I look down
and I'm, like, damn.
I done snagged
my [bleep] nipple on the fence.
She called 911, y'all,
and the EMT pull up.
A little white guy, and he
was, like, ma'am, what happened?
I'm, like, I think I snagged
my [bleep] nipple on the fence.
[laughter]
So, the EMT guy
tried to take my bra off.
And, you know,
I got a big set of titties.
I've had these same titties
since the third grade.
So, he's back there
trying to take my bra off
and he's struggling like hell.
I was, like, oh, evidently, you
never dealt with real titties.
Let me give you a hand, EMT.
So, I had to bend my back in
where my back titties
will help him unbutton my bra.
[laughter]
So, he take my bra loose,
and then my right titty
just fall out
like it was in a drive-by.
So, he picked it up and he was,
like, I think you've been shot.
I was, like,
you think I've been shot?
So, he lift my arm up and he
was, like, you got an entrance
and it came out
through your nipple.
That's your exit.
So, I'm thinking, like,
this [bleep] blew my nip off?
Like a bull's-eye?
And so he's, like,
I need to get you
to the hospital.
So, I get to the hospital,
y'all,
and the doctor examined
my titty and he was, like,
ma'am, he blew your nip off.
I'm, like, I [bleep] heard.
He was, like, well, ma'am,
you really lucky.
Because if you was a A-cup,
you would have died.
Them little titties
would've got you killed, baby.
These real titties.
They save life.
Thank you all so much.
I'm Ms. Pat.